there is an air of mystery about him we
don't really know what's going to happen
next tom felton might just have the best
flubbed line to make the final cut in
the harry potter franchise he's really a
victim of circumstances more than
anything i think the drago malfoy actor
improvised comedy gold which was no
surprise considering how much he goofed
around behind the scenes it wasn't all
fun and games though the actor also
dealt with some slaps in the face and
very off-putting embraces
i'm malfoy
draco malfoy while his positive and
enthusiastic demeanor on set made him a
great young actor it did also mean he
could end up being distracted by having
a little too much fun a natural
entertainer young felton took any chance
he could to goof around entertaining the
crew however there are times when it
probably got a bit too distracting
especially considering everyone around
the pair of actors was still acting as
if they were in a scene
since felton was always portraying the
villain being the kind young child he
was he made sure everyone knew he was
actually just really great at his job
and didn't have any real disdain for
radcliffe but we're not really enemies
we love each other really however he may
have spoken too soon
i have polaroids that i could show you
of tom
wow his hair like all spiked up these
boys managed mischief from their very
first days on set together thankfully we
got to watch the dynamic and
relationship between the two of them
grow on screen and off
was this the moment the one when emma
watson started crushing on her castmate
the adorable tom felton the actors
competitive sides started coming out
when they discovered they could spend
their time when the cameras weren't
rolling playing slaps
watson definitely impresses with her
skills felton had a great partner in her
for filming and slaps battles
tom felton and daniel radcliffe got on
much better behind the scenes than they
did on screen as draco and harry but
that didn't mean felton was going to let
radcliffe push him around
two young boys filming quidditch scenes
while sitting on top of broomsticks is
bound to get a bit silly
but the laughs stopped when felton
thought radcliffe was making a dig at
him
like his character felton wouldn't stand
to be disrespected if he wanted to pull
a draco move he could always just report
the incident to his father my father
heard about this
sometimes a blooper ends up being the
perfect moment and brings total gold to
the screen
filming the second movie felton made a
flub but kept rolling with it and turned
out this singer i didn't know you could
read
this wound up being one of the most
memorable lines of the whole series and
it was all born from a mistake
thank goodness for felton's wicked
comedy skills
it seems emma watson didn't shake her
competitive edge that came out playing
slaps during the first film since felton
got a whole lot more than he bargained
for it's not like a spell or something
it's actually like a physical hit
there's something very satisfying about
that the actor sort of brought it upon
himself since he knew there would be a
time when watson would have to slap him
for the cameras let's go on slap me
right now let's just do this to the
emotions since they had time to spare he
figured they could start practicing but
he wasn't expecting watson to dish out a
full-fledged hit i didn't know what to
do and i was just
like yeah that was that was really good
that was great while we know felton is
really a very sweet person sometimes
when between takes the actor would
continue on as if he were draco
fully embodying his character and all
the arrogance that comes with it
i don't like the common folk looking at
me you know by the time the fourth film
came along the actors were very
comfortable with each other and since
they spent so much time together on set
they could sometimes get a bit too hyper
and fool around a lot while by this
point emma watson was over her crush on
felton it looks like sparks could have
started flying oh look at that look at
that
lucky man
getting to film a big party scene is way
more fun when you're friends with
everyone the experience on set was
definitely more like a real dance thanks
to how much fun the actors had together
yeah man i've been doing my steps i've
been working my feet you see my feet
spending so much time on set the actors
have to come up with creative ways to
spend their time when they aren't
working when shooting the goblet of fire
the draco malfoy actor had some
seriously extensive hobbies
this activity actually makes a lot of
sense there's a whole lot of space for
them to use so they may as well take
advantage of the wide open area of a set
this is a fantastic place to work with
five harry potter films under his belt
by this point tom felton was able to do
his job really well and accommodate
whatever the director might have needed
pretty easily having such a great
understanding and portrayal of his
character
give us a thumbs up when it's going
the performer was so confident that he
could literally keep an eye on the
creatives while he was performing to get
notes on the go
and in between takes he could still take
a moment for the behind-the-scenes crew
felton seems like a bit of a dream actor
to have on set the drago malfoy actor
and his castmates had their acting
skills tested filming this high-stakes
battle without any of the magic
or any sound for that matter
aside from the couple of stupefies and
the sound of shoes on the ground felton
had to work to perform with the right
energy in total awkward silence
i don't even tell her what to do forget
the lines just just do your stuff i
don't know it's brilliant
clearly tom felton was thinking about
doing some magic before he entered the
room of requirement to film some intense
scenes in the second deathly hallows
film the room as usual managed to
deliver and felton was ready to perform
for my first trick
luckily he made the less cool but much
smarter decision to just save the magic
for his on-screen performance instead of
behind the scenes
after having not filmed a lot of high
action scenes in the past few films
before deathly hallows
it was definitely trickier to get back
into the groove this was a particularly
difficult action sequence to shoot with
lots of daring and intense scents to
pull off and they're still very
apprehensive about doing it it's just
you know they don't want to try not to
anticipate the table going the table
drop was a real struggle and took more
than a few takes to capture the right
way the team wound up keeping the actors
on their toes for real to bring out the
right reaction for the cameras and the
scene it's an instinct you know logic
logic brain thing you can't
override it the actors were in a perfect
mindset when it came to filming the
super high emotion scenes considering
they were already feeling a lot of
things about the whole process
emotions are coming easy which is great
for the scene felton was clearly jazzed
to be spending time with his old pals
and seemed to be treasuring every moment
they had together look at him
it's a hard life isn't it we have to
give the draco malfoy actor credit for
his incredible acting chops but
sometimes his job on set was made pretty
easy to do could barely sit stand within
five meters of him let alone him touch
me god i get the shivers even thinking
about it
can we blame him facing voldemort and
also dealing with his chilling embrace
is definitely not so comfortable the
fact that the he who shall not be named
actor improvised the hug definitely
caught felton off guard seeing how much
fun felton had behind the scenes reminds
us just how special an experienced the
harry potter saga was for so many young
actors it also makes us love the
performer even more his acting chops
combined with his great vibes on set
made for some pretty special moments
which blooper was your favorite
[Music]